thanks for uh thanks for having me it's
nice being in California even when it's
cloudy I'm going to be talking about
semi definite relaxation of k-means now
if you looked at the title in in the
program you notice that it looks
different from this and it actually
looks nearly identical to the next talk
and the abstracts also looked identical
we realized that we said we're going to
get the same talk and so what we decided
to do was to split the effort I'm gonna
give the setup and Soledad's gonna give
the punchline okay so here we go we got
some sponsors okay k-means problem so
someone gives you a bunch of points and
euclidean space and your job is to
cluster those points for this talk
you're gonna be told how many clusters
okay so let's say you get these these
points and I say there's three clusters
you can kind of see how the points ought
to be clustered but we want something
that a machine can accomplish so we give
the Machine an objective in this case
the k-means objective looks like this
the data points are X I these are living
in Euclidean space the decision variable
are these subsets of indices okay
c1 through CK so we're gonna be
partitioning the indices and we want to
partition the indices in such a way that
minimizes the sum of squared deviation
from the centroid of each subset okay
that's the k-means objective it turns
out that minimizing this objective
finding the partition that makes this
number as small as possible
that's an np-hard problem so there
exists ways of putting points even
points in the plane for which we we
don't have a quick solution a quick way
of finding the optimal
partition but we have a heuristic and
it's really popular it's hard code and
the MATLAB Python everything everyone
uses it it's called Lloyd's algorithm
look at Lloyd's algorithm so here we
have what appear to be three planted
clusters right we have the face of
Mickey Mouse as well as his two ears
right so we're going to run Lloyd's
algorithm we start with an
initialization so this big plus sign
right here is a member of the set
there's also this big circle as a member
of the set and you can barely see it
there's a big X right there those are
going to be the three initial centroids
we're going to carve out Voronoi regions
from those three points and that's going
to partition the rest of the data then
we're going to find centroids for those
subsets of the data so a centroid for
red will be somewhere over here centroid
for yellow will be somewhere over there
etc then we'll carve out Voronoi regions
again and we'll repeat so it looks like
this you can see that yellow is swinging
down to get the face of Mickey Mouse and
the two years are covered by the others
sooner or later it settles down it stops
updating and once it stops updating you
terminate the algorithm and you output
the the clusters the partition
unfortunately if you start with a
different initial ization you'll
conceivably end up with a different
clustering and you could imagine your
boss is asking for the best clustering
so you keep trying different
initializations and you get better and
better clusterings but when do you stop
when do you say okay I got it's a pretty
good clustering let's call it good
enough boss when do you know when to
stop
Lloyd's algorithm doesn't tell you want
to stop so there's another thing you can
do you can take that initial
optimization and pass to a semi-definite
program let's talk through how to do
that
first I'm going to define a matrix the
rows and columns of this matrix will be
indexed by the indices of our data
points let's say I have big and data
points this is an N by n matrix the IJ
entry of that matrix is the distance
squared between your two data points
okay
I claim this identity that my k-means
objective equals this trace thing okay
so I have my distance squared matrix I'm
multiplying it by a sum of scaled
versions of outer products so one sub CT
this is the indicator function of CT
he's 1 when the index is in CT 0
otherwise okay
the proof of this identity is simple
first D times this matrix the trace of
that my cycle and I just get a scalar
it's lighting up all of the entries in D
whose I and J entries both lie and CT so
I'm looking at some of these entries of
D what I can do is add 0 cleverly I'll
take so little C T here denotes the
centroid of Big C T he's that number
that vector and I open the square the
cross terms cancel and I get this I can
divide and add I end up with this
identity questions about that proof
that's right
I'm very much using Euclidean space
so if I look at this matrix I want to
give you some some intuition here so
shuffle the rows and columns so that the
first so many columns belong to C 1 the
second so many calls belong to C 2 etc
okay when I do that this matrix so 1 C 1
times 1 C 1 transpose will be this
component it's this shade of gray
because it's being scaled by one over
two seats piece so when C T is bigger
this becomes these numbers are smaller
okay so let's let's look at this matrix
and collect some features so each of
these entries are 1 over C 1 and there's
C one of them so when I add them up I
get one that's going to happen for each
of these rows ok so this matrix times
the all one's vector equals the all
one's vector I look at the trace of this
guy I get a contribution of one from
this block I get another contribution of
one total K blocks so the trace is K
each of these entries is either 1 over
CT for some T or at 0 so all these
entries are non-negative and finally
it's a sum of outer product so it's
positive semi-definite if I collect
these convex constraints I end up with
this program instead of minimizing the
trace of or half the trace of D times X
where X has this combinatorial form I
can relax to just ask X to satisfy these
convex constraints and this is a semi
definite program so we called a semi
definite relaxation
since we are minimizing over a larger
set a relaxed set the number that comes
out of this minimization is going to be
smaller or equal to the original k-means
problem so if it's a tight relaxation
it'll tell you exactly what the
clustering is if it's not tight but
close it'll give you an approximation to
what the best you could hope to do this
is the game we're going to be playing
any questions yeah that's the the hole
next to talks are about that okay other
questions so so even though the relation
you showed in the previous slide turning
of this trace porn is only for the
Euclidean norm still this trace form
also is what people solved for spectral
clustering with other DS right yeah so
if I throw this away I'm essentially
doing spectral clustering so and I hope
they use this for graphs and such yeah
no and and also respectfully to
different project inspectors looked a
way to try to optimize the King means
object right that was just be wondering
if there's no way to go back from the
spectral back to some Hey in fact
there's there's recent work to like
throw we call this the the k-means SDP
but they throw this SDP at other like
graph clustering problems they replace D
with some sort of laplacian thing and
they end up with guarantees so we we
came up what we didn't come up with this
some folks came up with this ten years
ago with the k-means objective in mind
but turns out it's useful elsewhere good
question any other comments
so I don't know if you know this but
solving a semi definite program can be
frustrating when when maybe you have big
data or something so case in point this
is hardly big data but sixty-four data
points will cost you 20 seconds whereas
Lloyd's built-in implementation on
MATLAB is a thousand South thousandth of
a second so there's some disparity here
what you can do this is pretty pretty
weird you can hunt for what's been
called a probably certifiably correct
algorithm okay so the model here is that
there's some Oracle that gives you the
optimal solution with high probability
okay and all you have to do is tell when
you're in that high probability event so
quickly certify optimality given this
likely solution the initial problem yeah
so you're actually solving the original
np-hard problem there's a there's a
distribution floating around in the
background and that distribution is
weighted towards easy cases apparently
but instances we're not we're not
necessarily using Lloyd's algorithm as
our Oracle but instances of the k-means
problem yeah the the data is random
under this why would you kill data
that's exactly right
so what we what we do here is we say we
have an algorithm that doesn't look at
the randomness but we have guarantees
that do look at the randomness so I have
something that works for general data
but I have a theorem that says hey even
if the data is cooked up with this
distribution then I'm able to say with
high probability my algorithm that works
in general works with high probability
for that model
this is not a worst-case analysis this
is an average case analysis for a
particular distribution equation how
well this works both practical instances
right I so you will fold it in the
second talk you're gonna see some really
amazing results in that regard I hope
you have amazing stuff okay so the way
this is going to work the way this is
even possible is that it turns out that
the convex relaxation this SDP is
actually tight with high probability
under a certain model of data and it's
possible to access this dual certificate
that comes from the convex relaxation
you can get that quickly from a an
Oracle solution I have my data right now
you have something which is if my data
was generated were generated on to me it
would have your solution of the works
how does it relevant how is it relevant
to my day my data will be worst case you
have something that's right so the
guarantee we have doesn't talk about
your data but our algorithm doesn't
require randomness just the guarantee
yes ma'am
even you run you give your theta and you
can run this thing and to works it gives
you a proof that something and if it
doesn't so it's a very fine very 35 so
you can have a certifier that I will
give you a solution to the Caymans
problem on arbitrary data it will tell
me is this an optimal solution or not
well you can tell you is this is an
optimal solution or I don't know if this
is a joke so it could be we could be
Ultima I would tell you but sometimes it
doesn't so sometimes we can give you a
lower bound when when you may know
document that tells you like a lower
bound value it's a 10% cap where the
randomness comes in is to say yeah
sometimes it doesn't know but under this
distribution it does know with high
probability and that's the that's where
the theory comes in
justification so you are like him a that
satisfies like exactly somebody to it
cuz it despite like approximate up
someone it says well there's two parts
so there's a there's a regime where we
could exact stuff because we can and
sometimes the data is too messy to get
exact and yet you can still get
approximate and I will know so I
ultimately 60 people dummies will 80%
there so there are gonna be two
certificates in the wild this this
certificate we're playing with here is
strictly exact Soledad's going to talk
about an approximate certificate mm-hmm
collaborators great I'm going to tell
you some stuff about cone programming
we're all gonna get on the same page
right here okay we got a set the dual
cone is the set of all vectors with
positive inner product not negative
inner product with everybody in that set
great there's a primal program on Maxim
this is a decision variable X as some
cost are maximizing this inner product
subject to some vector thing living in
one convex cone and my decision variable
living in another convex cone okay
convex cones include like the cones
you're visualizing right now ice cream
cone subspaces 0 vector whatever okay
if you permute the letters you get the
dual program and there's a reason that
this is the right notion of dual program
and the answer is this thing called weak
duality so if you take the blue vectors
from these two programs you note that
they lie in dual cones of each other
that means their inner product is
necessarily non-negative same with the
red vectors so I got these non-negative
vectors and they each feature of minus
sign if I split over that minus sign and
I move over to the other side I end up
with a sequence I always have if I'm
feasible in the primal program my value
is less than or equal to the value of
anybody in the dual program okay so the
maximum is less than or equal to the
minimum it turns out that a lot of times
it's equals that the optimizer over here
has the same value as the optimizer over
there so what that means is let's say I
have somebody that's dual feasible and
he has value equal to somebody whose
primal feasible well then what that dual
feasible guy is is he's certifying the
optimality
of that primal feasible guy because his
bad you can't get any bigger he must be
maximum it's a dual certificate this is
a proof of optimality so another way to
unwrap that logic
it's called complementary slackness so
if I have an X and I have a Y X is
primal optimal and Y is dual optimal
simultaneously both of these things are
happening if and only if X is primal
feasible he satisfies these constraints
y is dual feasible satisfying those
constraints and these inner products are
exactly equal x and y played nicely
together they satisfy complementary
slackness when these three things happen
that's equivalent to x and y being
optimal in their respective programs any
questions
here's a picture I find this picture to
be helpful so imagine you have your
primal program living in one space you
have the dual program living in another
space you take their Cartesian product
this is the set of all points X comma Y
is primal and dual feasible ok I have a
set of points that play nice together
they satisfy complementary slackness
with each other what strong duality says
is the intersection of these two sets
are the set of points where the first
coordinate is primal optimal and the
second coordinate is dual optimal ok
you remind you what our game is an
Oracle tells us something that is
purportedly primal optimal my task is to
certify that he's primal optimal so I
get this point right here
I think it's this point first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to check is he
primal feasible okay then I'm gonna ask
hey what's a y that plays nicely with
that x YY that's landing on this lime
and then I'll ask if that y is dual
feasible if he is that I just certified
that but the Oracle gave me is primal
optimal that make sense so this was
introduced by Afonso Bandera when he was
thinking about the stochastic block
model and it turns out that when you
solve minimum by section you can pass to
a semi definite program and there's a
unique y that corresponds with X
complementary slackness gives you
everything you need to uniquely
determine what Y would have to be and
then you can just test if he's dual
feasible it's a semi definite program so
that amounts to an eigenvalue problem
yes sir I mean we have a problem that is
np-hard is np-hard to approximate so now
you cannot achieve
you can't break the NP hardness you
don't know I can't prove this P equals
NP so what are you going to what kind of
guarantee I mean how does it is
consistent with the houses of a boxing
k-means the result what is the result in
terms of how does it relate to the
houses results that we know we are if
someone gives me something that's
optimal
I can certify that I can prove that it's
optimal in a lot of cases that's the
result like it's with high probability
of a stochastic model but it will work
but it will not work for put it beside
your poem you shouldn't be half right
so for data mining its distributed like
the stochastic book they also call it
the stochastic model then it will work
with poverty point 9
so the distribution you could say it's
cooked up in a way that the hard
instances receive vanishing probability
turns out that k-means is harder you
don't get a unique why you actually have
to make choices and this is frustrating
we don't know what the optimal choice of
dual certificate is for this procedure
in k-means case that's an open question
like a classification of problems like
SDPs whatever in the setting with y is
not universal and Y is some
classification saying these probably
easier than these others I wouldn't be
surprised if so but I don't know about
it yeah
it's all that do you know the answer
I don't know why I put you on the spot
alright so here's the there's a little
technicality here with this method so I
told you yeah it's easy to test dual
feasibility it's an eigenvalue problem
how do you solve eigenvalue problems
again I use the power method so that
requires a random initialization so it
could be that I randomly initialize
really close to a bad eigen space so the
best I can honestly deliver is
arbitrarily high confidence that that
the Oracle gave me an optimal solution
does that make sense
but there's a this Big O as high in
spectral gap but the number of nines and
my confidence I get a nine every
iteration so yes nope so would you get
rid of this so afonso had a conversation
with dan Spielman who said that yeah we
don't know how to get around this like
for numerical linear algebra we have no
idea had it how to get around that so
that's the that's the extent that I'm
aware of like yeah power method is not
the only way but at the moment modern
technology we don't know how to get
around this
you'd like to hook just so that you feel
like you don't know how to get around
just if you want linear time yeah I just
want I want linear time like yeah but
that quadratic is not helpful to me yeah
speaking of linear time this method
works and it's fast so if the horizontal
axis is the number of data points we're
pushing around and the vertical axis is
the run time this is log log scale so
you should think the slope is the
exponent
okay so kami this is kind of an eye
chart k-means plus plus in MATLAB is
constant time until it's linear time
okay it eventually becomes linear great
if you run the k-means SDP is off the
chart yeah too slow you can so this is
for two clusters so you can
intelligently invent a spectral method
that is linear time because it's low
rank you appeal to that you get linear
time and what's even faster is running
our pcc algorithm so this is how you
think about this you take this amount of
time to solve k-means plus plus now the
Oracle gave you a solution and then you
take this amount of time to certify that
the Oracle gave you the right solution
okay
yes this is that's right you can prove a
theorem this is a particular model of
data called the stochastic ball model I
want you to imagine planted clusters
okay so I have balls unit balls in
Euclidean space each ball has a rotation
invariant probability distribution okay
and I draw a bunch of points from each
ball okay now I throw the balls away I
just have the points now and I need to
run
let's say the Oracle tells me what the
plan clustering is and I need to certify
yep that's right that's the plan
clustering using the this pcc method
okay we have a theorem that says it
works provided the balls don't intersect
so the distance between two centers if
it's less than two yes sir so there's
this paper I came around out around the
key means plus plus paper the same year
or something like that they have a bunch
of these hypotheses you can't actually
verify they certainly assume something
about the clustering that you don't know
if it's true but but under that Richard
these really bizarre hypotheses they got
these bounds on the optimality of King
earth at Keeney's plus plus would
converge
the if you were to and you're not asking
for very much here if you're to ask for
impossible stuff would you be able to
still so you're saying if I if I throw
more stuff into my hypothesis do I get
the same conclusion yes but there's a
line of work of saying what is easy that
for k-means clustering yeah the several
types of assumptions under which you can
show that k-means clustering becomes
easy the problem is that none of them is
realistic none of them have been
supported so this is all simple this is
not really I think I mean if your data I
mean the question on such easy data with
other methods maybe also look first so I
want to disambiguate something I am NOT
proving this is not a theorem about
k-means plus plus okay just I'm looking
at this is this is your data model
and they have another assumption which
was a data model that was kind of
bizarre don't were the cores so like
you'd have like a cluster that sort of
property about distance from the
centroid of it they required you knowing
the answer it did the bear part when I
talk about a most obscure bodies yeah
that one yes it's a very strong result
yeah and it implies that the data
centers of 200 times further away than
average distance of the poetry Center
and then this assumption k-means plus
plus or some version of yeah yeah
if you plus possible work in the
situation you have different ease the
situation and different I would assume I
work on having here the same thing
there exists a lame scenario where you
have like this happening you split that
and group those yeah okay
so so I need them to not intersect plus
some fudge right and the fudge decays
with the dimension all right now it's
romantic
so the SDP is tight less romantic when
whenever this happens so this is what I
just told you the SCP is tight from a
previous paper with this threshold and a
more recent paper gave this other
threshold these are not comparable some
are better than others in different
regimes we don't know what the best what
the correct answer is each one of these
came from a different choice of dual
certificate okay it's an art form we
don't know how to resolve the art
you might guess that the correct answer
is to just make sure they don't
intersect and you're good
that is wrong so imagine two circles in
r2 whose centers are separated by 2.08
and then solve k-means if you see this
but it's the partition who goes this way
that circle ate part of that the other
circle
this isn't uniquely optimal obviously
that one also works if it's 2.09 then
the planted clustering is optimal so
there's a threshold here it would be
interesting to know if that Thresh like
to what extent does that threshold
persist in higher dimensions yes sir
your certificate requires computing like
doping in space of some matrix right
because advanced nature so sparse it
ends up being low rank if you point slow
and low dimensions yeah so basically
your skill like your chart with temple
eight points little very low dimensional
a so otherwise you wouldn't be able to
six dimensions six dimensions two
clusters itself in do yeah all right
we were going for like can we get linear
time cuz k-means plus plus is linear sdp
very nonlinear so yeah okay so the
stochastic ball model is really nice
someone told me that recently but it's
pretty idealistic right
what about Messier data what can you say
then so in the I'm at a time but I'm
going to show you part to you real quick
part two says yeah the SDP still
contains signal when you're going here I
got 10 minutes do we
[Music]
all right let's do this
we'll be five yeah that feels better
okay so we're looking at Gaussian
mixtures this is Messier right because
you can have a point from one Gaussian
land in the middle of another Gaussian
good luck figuring out where he belongs
okay joint work
well let's think about that SDP again
remember I had the trace was K x1 equals
1
you gotta yada yada ok I some of these
constraints tell me that X is doubly
stochastic he's a doubly stochastic
matrix let's think about how I can
leverage that information remember what
X oft looks like when he's integral when
he's what we want him to look like it's
like this right what I can do
imagine P is the short fat matrix whose
columns are my data points okay and I
want to hit that on the right with the
planted solution say what the first
column of X opt is going to do is take
the sample average of the data points in
the first planted cluster
the second column is going to do the
same thing etc so I'm gonna have so many
copies of the first centroid an
empirical centroid than so many copies
of the second empirical centroid etc
this is what clean data what a what an
integral solution would look like that's
how he would behave interacting with the
original data set
now what if X opt is not integral right
what if my data is so messy that the SDP
optimizer is some other looking matrix
okay it doesn't look like that so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna show you
alright I ran the k-means SDP on this
data set okay I got exit this data set
this point is one of the columns of the
to buy whatever matrix P right and then
I multiply that on the right by the
optimizer of the of the k-means SDP if
it were integral then when I morphed
these points into those things I would
get these guys morphing into their
empirical centroid these points would
morph into their empirical centroid and
those points would morph into their
empirical century I'm going to show you
the morph that comes from the SDP
optimizer it's gonna look different pay
attention you're not going to be able to
see this afterwards you looking here
comes
okay so you can't tell right now but
these points represent a bunch of points
they all came together and then I get
some low rank noise okay there's a lot
of signal coming from this sdp can we
harness it to say something about the
true clustering okay
so you can think of this as a denoise
version of the original data set we're
gonna exploit that we're going to try to
estimate the Gaussian centers so at this
point the the rest of this talk we're
just looking at we're proving theorems
about how their signal that the SDP
optimizer captures the next talk is
going to answer the question you want to
answer which is how well does it
approximate the k-means value yes sir so
this ami [ __ ] mean shift is when you
move hey everything to this centroid
above the points in its neighborhood and
iteratively do this it it looks like
this process that's the mean shift
clustering I can't answer I don't know
another question you could ask which
sounds a lot like that question that's
what if you ramp camions SP on this and
the answer is it would go to one of
these looking things that feels like
what you're saying okay so how do we
prove a theorem that denoising gives me
some signal so this represents this is a
symbol for that I'm done yeah I am done
look at that you can do some cool stuff
using stuff from guidan for sheena it's
so awesome you're missing out then you
round you get some cool stuff and the
next talk is going to answer your
question any questions from you all
right thank you
[Applause]
[Music]